[Music]
uh william shatner went to space i guess
oh and came down and was explaining
how he felt to jeff bezos and watch what
jeffy does
god damn it
there's audrey powers a big hug from her
sister
captain kirk himself the great william
shatner
hugging him because he's like holy [ __ ]
i'm alive still customer chris boss
housing the first full australian
citizen to go to space and back hugging
how many ridges are in your back dude
that's insane
you can hear his life
some big hugs from their loved ones
how'd it feel william
that's what i thought you have to work
on so hard you have to work on it
because not only is it different than
what you thought
it happened
you know what my
people
the impression i had that i never
expected
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just so he can do some [ __ ] boy [ __ ]
[Applause]
he didn't get to finish what he's saying
he's literally describing he's like
having an epiphany
of how insane space was in jeff
hold on i want to do one
[Music]
smile
go back and watch that again watch
trying to talk to your boy in the club
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
shooting up
and you see this blue ski oh wait i want
to do one
champagne give me one of those [ __ ]
bottles yeah i'm popping bottles right
now yeah william i know i've been up
there before yeah it's crazy whatever
shut the [ __ ] up
she says
[Laughter]
have you seen this reporter
i'm trying to shoot up something else
shooting up and just seeing the earth
from that perspective was so beautiful
not as beautiful as that [ __ ]
reporter over there hold on watch this
watch it someone get her yo run popping
champagne
you shouldn't have worn a white shirt
today
damn [ __ ] boy jeff bezos yeah man
he's
he's seriously on his [ __ ] boy [ __ ]
right now she had you know she had the
belly out and he couldn't resist he's
like god damn
i'm about to go crazy
this trend
yo william shatter just looking at the
ground and [ __ ]
right he's just like [ __ ] i just got
damn um
blown off
by the world's hottest billionaire he
man it's so hilarious how he didn't give
a [ __ ] with anything about anything
william shatner had to say i know the
whole time here you can tell on his face
he's like when's this going to be over
yeah it's a mistake asking this guy how
space was
he's like i've been up 40 times already
i know this guy is [ __ ] blue from
what whatever stupid your observation
you're about to make to me you know
the thing i didn't expect william hurry
up
hurry up
you know what i'm trying to smash this
very very sure dude you know what i
didn't expect william
shanice from channel five i've been
trying to get her for
years
he's like i have the the view from up
there yeah dude totally yeah yeah
i'll catch you yeah i'll see you later
yo so shanice
listen hey hey hey
stop talking
all right
when you shoot yo will will he like he's
like he shoot up he like meets him he's
like this with his hand he's like yeah
yeah
shut up
stop talking oh word shh
she said when you shoot
when you shoot up he grabs his wrist and
turns it turns it and puts his own hand
[Music]
stop talking
will yo captain kirk captain shut the
[ __ ] up
okay put a kirk in it dude
okay
shut the [ __ ] up
thanks you know i sent up a couple of
those uh
minimum wage people from like montana
last week completely [ __ ] this up for
me yeah i thought chinese was never
going to come back got off the [ __ ]
they're blabbing just hanging on this
spaceship just shut up you know i gotta
be billionaire yeah i gotta be
billionaire billy yeah
so be cool you're one you're like me boy
you got money okay you know what it's
like just shut the [ __ ] up we have
nothing to talk about we have
nothing in common will
we've both seen the sky from up there
and down here that's it except after
this
you're gonna go back to your old ass
wife
and i'm gonna [ __ ] that 25 year old
okay
we're not alike we're not the same we'll
just i don't give a [ __ ] about how space
looked to you
your saggy ass body
just mean out of nowhere what i didn't
expect which you didn't expect was to
ever go into space captain kirk because
you only did it in the movies
you understand
you're irrelevant the most you're ever
gonna be is the guy who played a guy who
went to space you had to come to the guy
who can put you in space and that's me
i'm the real captain kirk
you understand call me it yeah what's my
name
no say what's my name
say it dude
come on we'll say it what's my name
no i'm saying i can't hear you a little
louder shanice come over here give me a
little louder so shanice can hear what
were you just about to call me watch
this were you just about to call me
the real captain kirk that's right
that's right i'll give you one of those
champagne bottles
it just pops it and pours it
he's standing there just defeated as
[ __ ]
champagne just pouring just like a
shower is this
he shouldn't eat ready for some general
mayhem
damn we just [ __ ] on captain kirk badly
what are you what are you cap what are
you
say what are you
what are you i'm a fake little space
[ __ ]
there you are
you're my fake little space [ __ ] aren't
you
now run along and go do another
progressive commercial
and get out of my [ __ ] face
you has been
well if you want like a if you want a
good experience on space coming to the
ship will yeah
you know we'll let you finish if you sit
on this couch we'll we'll let you tell
that story that you were trying to tell
yeah yeah we won't cut you off
we're not [ __ ] like that
damn we should actually get william
shatner on
we should really try to get him on
and play him that clip be like what were
you going to say because it didn't seem
like jeff
gave a [ __ ] yeah but we wanted to know
what was it like from out there
well it's it's really we know dude
are you struggling for words maybe just
look out the [ __ ] window [ __ ] it's
right there